[Musique]
une composition monumental un christ qui
s'en posent en premier plan le christ
devant hérode de georges l'allemand vous
accueille le regard accroché par le
raffinement des traits vous voyez un jeu
sur les visages dont le travail à la
plume et ensuite au la vie qui est
vraiment très fin qui donne vie à
l'image avec très divin port royal des
champs plonge dans le secret celui d'
oeuvre jusqu'ici inconnu du grand public
une cinquantaine de dessins des
collections du musée des beaux-arts
d'orléans
on a vraiment des feuilles incroyable
qui commence vers 16 130 et qui vont
jusqu en 1720 donc un 17e sec très large
qui correspond au règne de louis xiii et
au règne de louis xiv pour vraiment
avoir des grandes périodes du dessin
française
de l'esc hisse au dessin abouti
plusieurs techniques sont rassemblés la
pierre noire privilégié au xvième siècle
permettant une grande rapidité ou la
plume lancre et le la vie l'exposition
se découvre de quatre manières on peut
apprendre tout un tas d'éléments sur la
manière dont le dessin est utilisé sur
le décès sur la manière dont on
fabriquait le dessin sur l'usagé qu'on
en faisait ou encore sur les
représentations religieuses au 17e
rentrer dans l'exposition suivant 4 axes
à la fois la chronologie à la fois les
techniques à la fois les représentations
religieuses et également la manière dont
le dessin était utilisé par les artistes
le dessin religieux n'existait pas cette
époque mais le sujet pieux trouve sa
place dans le grand siècle port royal
des champs illustre son patrimoine
confessionnelles